feminism advocates for men it's always  for women really because they're  advocating for men to be more  emotionally available but who does that  benefit the men as well women are the  women just women it's leverage so for  for your example of when you're seeing  someone that was telling you to be more  like emotionally available you've done  that right you've done that in a way i  told her about my frustrations okay and  then when you broke up  she said that you were dumping on on her  yeah a whole diet about men using women  as emotional experts right  how did you feel  how did you feel  when you opened up emotionally ever so  slightly terrible see opening up  emotionally doesn't really  and i would i would go as far to assume  this is how all men work  opening up emotionally does not solve  the problem it just gives another person  leverage to then criticize you about how  you're reacting to the problem